what we're going to look at today okay
is um really really cool because what we
have in math is kind of um
two different kinds of mats and I don't
know could you raise your hand for me if
anyone has heard these words these
adjectives applied to maths before
anyone anyone are not pure and apply
maths
yeah keep your hand up if you know at
all what any of that means
yeah throw a hella go how would you
summarize it for us good yeah okay so I
think it's a great succinct illustration
of it let me try and give you an example
of these pure mats pure mats
okay this is pure maths
on us what should do next it's a type
okay let's have a look at that right is
that interesting that interesting
guess what it's been mathematically
proven that noughts and crosses is an
unwinnable game if you know you're doing
your course it can be mathematically
proven it's not just like oh I played
100 games and once we play 200 games
together you've worked out how to do it
right you really literally come in it
should be tie every time that's been
proven mathematically what does that
have to do with anything
well much it's pure maths okay it's
maths for its own interest it's just
like someone thought that was kind of
curious and weird applied maths it's
kind of like the opposite its massing
the nitty-gritty of the real world like
I've got a problem and it involves
numbers and I need just saw this somehow
let me bring some math to bear in order
to do that
so what we're going to do today is
really at the heart of what it means to
have a five minutes but we give you guys
problems like say what you mean we can't
reason it so financial mess okay
that's applied math it's real problems
but even so it's problems that we've
given to you it's like okay David has a
part-time job working yet Minerva's Mack
is and he earns such-and-such and how
much Tasi play ball that's a problem we
have contrived to given to you today you
guys are recovering the problem so very
quickly I want to show you something
which I'm sure you have a look at quite
a bit in recent times so you've been
probably staring at this map quite a bit
thinking about you this is the scenario
that we are in these this is the kind of
environment in which we are trying to
solve a problem okay now we are trying
to head towards particular different
solutions so today I'm going to try and
give you some tools to investigate the
feasibility of some of solutions we can
consider okay now the first primary
thing we're trying to work with is well
look this area that we're looking at
what are we actually working with you
now it's interesting because I think
some of you guys have noticed that this
is not as desertified and that's
actually probably the word than it is
now how old is this photos anyone knows
yeah say it's almost 10 years old now no
wonder that some of this actually still
looks like grass unlike what it was like
so we've got an area in here that we're
interested in working on for instance
okay there's an area in there okay now
just to make it hotter keep the lights
first place just get over there perfect
okay
so now you can see it fairly clearly all
right now just before I talk about the
area itself just under how many of you
have looked at this shape and noticed
how unusual it is in fact the serpentine
wall is the graph of a sine curve which
some of you may know what that is and
some of you will discover that later
this year and not only is it a sine
curve but it's it too curved around sine
curve which is a tangent to this
parabola can you see it there in green
just highlighted there it's a bit hard
to make up that's okay that's all right
it's important you guys can see it right
now it's it's a pear toy I've been
putting these you guys get it that line
there is a tangent that forms around
here following the curve a parabola
right so Architects are often very
mathematical people and they kind of
sneaked into their designs all right now
which I work out let me get rid of that
oh yes
it's like that small shape uh actually I
suspect it was in the opposite order I
think the school is designed first and
the emblem came after that I suspect
that's exactly right
you can see that you can see the scene
punching okay and you've got the diamond
okay now a primary problem that you guys
are going to encounter it is well
suppose suppose we wanted to cover this
whole thing in new grass right make it
nice and green and alive okay then it's
gonna cost a lot of money but the
question of whether this is going to be
worth it or not is very much dependable
how much money how long is it all these
kinds of questions okay so this shape
here and we might have we might hit the
Lights again it may be this shape here
is a bit of a mess right tell me tell me
what kinds of shapes do we know how to
calculate the areas on okay
rectangle so we'll give me another one a
circle okay so we have like a
right-angled triangle we can do some
lengthy we ought to give area here but I
think I know that's interesting in that
one dimension hexagons shape if I
understand correctly and you can tell me
if I'm wrong on this one I didn't think
we learn a formula for the area of a
hexagon do it I don't think we do now
there is a way to do it isn't there
right we can divide up this shape into
other shapes that we know how to
calculate okay so here we go on your
piece of paper to jot this down first
and then I want you go and have a minute
later here's our first approach for this
and the hexagon has taught us what
direction to go in
method number one to take this wieder
looking thing right like the hexagon we
can consider it as method number one
opposite shape or a composit figure okay
so we remember this right we've seen
very simple as before and like you
pointed out this one on the board that
hexagon over there how can I divide it
up how shall I do by the end okay so six
triangles we work Windows there is the
six let's do it let's see okay so I
could put a point in the middle then go
outwards or I could just do this that
would um that would achieve the same
stuff is still old still triangles okay
now here's the thing right this is great
this is perfect it's perfectly embodies
what we're doing right this hexagon how
many ways could you divide it up into
training Louis there are loads where I
could put the lines anywhere I could put
points I could construct the whole point
is there are many varying and valid ways
to solve this problem okay but they all
come back to this idea that it's a
figure made up of multiple shapes have a
look at this one this here method 1
comes in shape
this here is an irregular shape right
but we can divide it out we can consider
it as the combination of several other
shapes okay now there's a really good
reason why you might consider that for
instance I some straight lines here
right so I could divide up the triangle
I'm here or maybe even a rectangle of
sorts
okay but then you've also got these arcs
around here what shape should I use to
get close to those I'll use circles or
semi circles or quadrant or whatever was
relevant so method one the cop is a
figure is about approximating our area
that's okay I forgive your most foreign
interest like them approximating our
area with a whole bunch of other shapes
with other shapes that we have formulas
for now just as an aside this is a
classically mathematical thing to do and
in fact all the way through your
mathematical career so much of what you
do mat is designed to do exactly this
take a problem that you don't know how
to solve look at this mess
can we transform it into a problem that
we do know how to solve all of these
less perfect geometric figures we don't
exist in real life but they're pretty
close to what we actually want I'm not
finished yet
but I've just Illustrated a bit of his
time you guys will need to finish this
right and you can see I've got a big
rectangle ish shape right
I say rectangle ish because it's not
exactly a rectangle if you pay very very
close attention these angles here are
not all right angles slightly off I
don't know rectangle here top triangles
here now I've got these curved shapes in
blue the reason why is if you look at
actual shape they're these blue shapes
are not part of the area I'm interested
in right so for me this is my code to
kind of don't add these you should
subtract them now here's the great thing
about this right this is a real life
problem this is a glide measurement okay
there's no back a book people were
asking me questions like how many checks
should I use people ask me questions
like this part up here right your
lettuce little bit of a curve can I not
just make it
I tried which is a fantastic question
because guess what
maybe we can all I want is an actual
number out the other end a hundred
square meters 200 300 I'm not even sure
what ballpark on a par the reason why is
because this whole time we're cuttin
Missy
some crucial information any suggestions
what would I actually need yeah I
suppose you have Russell I need some
measurements right so if you have a look
of your image you can do that now you
have a look on your image right nestled
in the bottom right hand corner okay
there's a little bar and it says should
say 10 meters do you see there Timmy's
so now you can actually make some
measurements pixel for pixel to work out
what the size of this thing is like
you're gonna need to do some conversions
you're gonna need to calculate it fairly
quickly but it can be done